- So much of what I think about
is how people love to save time
and how much I value your time
and how much empathy I have for your time.
And so, we are doing more mash ups
of some of our best key notes.
You just might not have an
hour and a half to get it all
and so I'm super excited about
this little mashup right here.
And I'm also very excited
because this keynote also led
to the deck, the PDF, the
presentation about how I make
content in today's world.
So this is all very meta for me.
This was obviously a very special day
that has led to the ability for me
to communicate to you about
ways you can be doing it for yourself,
but most of all,
wanted to make sure that
all of you got the themes
of this special talk.
(film rolling)
Positivity and offense always wins,
historically, always.
(upbeat music)
The reason I spend my
time on talking about this
is not because I wanna be a
fuckin' motivational speaker
and fluffy, fluff,
fluff and rah, rah, rah.
It's because it's the fuckin' thing.
It's the thing.
Life is binary.
It's either offense or defense.
When you bet on optimism,
when you're on the offense,
you do something super duper interesting.
You start suffocating excuses.
If you asked me the number one thing
I wake up every morning and
thank that my parents did,
is I never saw either one of
them complain about jack shit.
And it basically created
learned behavior for me.
I am incapable of actually
complaining about shit.
And that has become the
foundation of my success.
Yes, it is absolutely
difficult for all of us.
We all have stuff.
Do I believe some people have it,
do I believe a white
male has more approach,
of course, yes I do.
Here's my problem,
my problem is if anybody has ever done it
with your circumstances,
then you have nothing to talk about
in the mindset that I want for you to win.
Everybody's in a slump.
Like everybody's got adversity,
there's always something.
To me, somebody's always got it worse.
There's 7.7 billion people
and unless I'm in some weird little cage
in some fourth world country,
that means I'm not in last place.
Which means I have
nothing to complain about.
Like, you live in America.
- (man) Fuck yeah.
- The fuck are you complaining about?
(laughter and cheering)
We have it the best
and all I see is people sitting around
and dwelling around dumb shit,
around what they don't have,
instead of focusing on what they do have.
A lot of us were born with
what we were born with.
Right, like, you're only so pretty,
you're only so smart, you're only so fast,
you're only what you are.
It's like a great poker player, right,
a great poker player
doesn't need the best hand
every time to win.
It's how she or he
navigates with that hand.
We're not gonna change
who we are or where we were born
or to whom we were born with.
But no matter where you are
in the life cycle right now,
we all have the opportunity to start
looking at it a little different.
And to me very frankly,
I just think we spend an
enormous amount of time
on dumb shit when we have
ambition to do so much more.
When I was nine years old
and opened the door for an
elderly woman at a McDonald's
she reacted as if I won
the Nobel Peace Prize.
What my mom did was super smart,
she overreacted on
everything that I was doing
that was a good human trait
and she held me accountable
for things that didn't matter,
like grades, she didn't let me,
I got punished four
times a year, every year
from the time I was in third grade
until my senior year of high school.
My mom built huge self esteem in me
and I feel like the biggest
reason I am who I am today
to everybody is cause I feel so guilty
and so grateful for what she did for me,
that I want to do it for everybody else.
I promise you, if you wanna be pumped
professionally and personally,
there's one thing that will
drive you to the biggest success
it's called self awareness.
And I want that for every fuckin' person
because let me tell you something,
it fucking is the best.
It's such a good place to be.
When you can get to that
place, amazing shit happens.
You know why, cause you
stopped being scared.
When you're not scared, you do shit.
When you're scared, you do nothing.
Like what are you scared of?
Like what, you're dad's gonna be like
I told you you're a loser.
What are you fuckin' fearful of.
Your sister making fun of you
cause she's got a better job?
Fuck her.
Cool, don't forget my friends,
you could be winning 28
nothing at half time and lose.
So you're older sibling that's
got a great fucking job,
could be a crack head next year.
(laughter)
Could, could.
Because he's had a whole
facade the whole time
fuckin' trying to suck
your parents dick, right?
(laughter)
And he's actually insecure inside
and something went wrong at the office
and he starts fucking
doing coke on the side.
Guys, don't you understand
how this is played.
This is why I'm petrified of
fuckin' eighth place trophies.
If you grow up where everybody
gets an eighth place trophy,
you're actually scared of losing
and then you're fucked
because losing is real.
I love, I swear on my
fucking kid's health,
I'm obsessed with losing.
I fucking love losing.
I love losing cause I know exactly
what you're thinking about my loss
and I can't wait to stick
it in your fuckin' face
when I come back.
(cheering)
I'd actually have a whole
different new concept,
I recommend fucking up on purpose.
(laughter)
I'm being serious.
It's so much better to eliminate
expectations from the get.
Then you're playing with house money.
If you're scared of
other people's opinion,
fuck up on purpose, then
everybody thinks you suck.
Shit, then it's all up side.
You suck at a ton of shit, good.
So does everybody else.
You're also probably pretty
fucking rad at some thing.
Try as many things as possible
until you figure out what
you're rad at and you like
and go fucking do that
for the rest of your life
and stop giving a fuck
about everybody else.
(cheering)
You have to figure out who's opinion
is dictating your
actions besides yourself.
Like it is in my mindset
that literally every negative
thing that happens to me,
is my fucking fault.
Literally your ability to
be the bigger man and woman
in every situation, even
though nine out of ten times
you may be right,
is the variable of your success
both within an organization
and compounded when you
go out into the real world
and this takes me back to where I started,
please understand the following,
being nice is ROI positive.
One of the biggest reasons a lot of you
don't do the right thing
is because you expect
somebody to do that in return
after you do it.
And that expectation,
the reason I'm good is cause I give
with zero expectation in return.
A lot what works for me is
I do it for the right reasons,
I'm all in, I don't mind if I lose,
I actually weirdly prefer it,
and if I do great for you
and then I need you in a
year and you don't deliver,
I'm cool with that too.
I'm empathetic.
Maybe you didn't get it,
maybe you're not a good person,
maybe you've got some shit
on your mind right now
that didn't allow you to come through.
I think the expectation of others
and the opinions of others
are disproportionally guiding your life
and I think that you will
end up regretting that
in your older years.
(applause)
- (man) Thank you, that was great.
(upbeat music)
- So go fuck up.
(cheering)